hey crazies if you haven't heard light
bends when it passes from something like
air into water or glass the result is
weird optical illusions like this in
true science Asylum style we're gonna
question everything let me show you how
deep this rabbit hole goes this episode
was made possible by generous supporters
on patreon alright let's start with a
basic line of reasoning a TV clone is
driving along the concrete when he
suddenly encounters some mud as you can
imagine this noticeably slows the ATV
but not all at once the front right tire
slows down before the other three tires
that means there's a speed and balance
on either side of the ATV which causes
the ATV to turn its path becomes bent
what's this have to do with light
I'm getting there chill out light seems
to do the same thing let's say a drone
is hovering in the air near my scuba
clone the light that gets to his eyes
isn't going to be the light that went in
a straight line see light travels at a
different speed in the air than a dozen
water well not really but but it's
useful to pretend that it does light
certainly seems like it slows down at
least on our level of existence so its
path is going to bend
just like the ATVs path did just just go
with it the light that was originally
headed for scuba Clones eyes doesn't
make it there it gets bent away we call
this refraction which comes from the
Latin word refractive meaning broken up
the light that enters his eyes actually
came from over here which means he
doesn't see the drone where it actually
is wait what chill out let me explain
aiyaaa we judge where things are by
subconsciously assuming light travels
along a straight line it's called line
of sight however that's not always the
case so when we see light coming at us
from a certain angle our brains assume
it never bent the light is interpreted
as if it was always traveling in a
straight line skubick alone see
the drone over here this even explains
the straw illusion at the beginning of
the video if we look at this from above
the straw scatters light in all
directions but the light headed directly
toward our eyes doesn't ever make it
there the light that actually gets to
our eyes came from this direction what
our brain thinks it came from a
different direction we see the straw in
a different place optical illusion
explained how are you calculating all
those angles though Snell's law we've
got the incoming angle on one side and
the transmitted angle on the other this
n is called the refractive index this is
the number you look up in a table
somewhere like this one from engineering
tool box each material has its own
refractive index and how they compare
determines the bending of light a change
in the incoming angle means a change in
the transmitted angle the refractive
index is also related to the apparent
speed of a light beam in that material
speaking of speed there might be a
better way to look at this let's say our
drone from earlier is being flown by
drone clone when it runs out of energy
and begins falling into the lake wanting
to get there as fast as possible his
immediate thought is to run in a
straight line unfortunately when he
reaches the water it slows him down and
he can't get there in time
goodbye drone a straight line might be
the fastest path if you're running
through air the whole time or even water
the whole time but if you have to run
through one and then the other a
straight line is not the fastest this
straight line is the shortest distance
but that doesn't mean it's the shortest
time drone clone can actually get a
faster time by staying out of the water
a bit longer since he runs faster
through the air but that would give you
the impression that he needs to stay in
the air as long as possible which isn't
true either that path is too big a
distance the fastest path is somewhere
in between that's the one that balances
distance with speed something like this
a similar thing happens with light the
path light takes is described by
something called faire Maas principle
which states that light will always take
the path that requires the least in
of time not the shortest distance the
least time light does what drone clone
needed to do without making any
conscious decisions of any kind but why
though why do those two laws work that
way
quantum mechanics here we go again let's
ask ourselves a question what if light
takes all possible paths not just the
least time path I mean we know a beam
doesn't do this but maybe individual
photons can somehow all right now let's
take another look at scuba clone we know
light travels from the drone to his eyes
but we don't actually know the path all
we really know is that it started at the
drone and ended at his eyes each photon
could have taken any path between those
two points we might secretly hope it's
the least time path but we don't know
that for sure
see a photons behavior is described by a
wave a wave of probability and according
to quantum mechanics all of these paths
contribute to that probability yes all
of them we use the same technique in a
recent video about mirrors if you're
getting uncomfortable you should go
watch that I'll wait
okay welcome back rather than deal with
wave mechanics we're going to imagine
the photons wave is a little arrow
called a phase vector or phasor for
short over time that arrow spins around
at a pace given by the frequency of the
photon visible light frequencies are
pretty high though so this arrow is
spinning around like crazy fast fast
fast ultimately each available path for
the photon takes a different amount of
time so those spinning arrows end up in
different orientations when they're done
to find the total probability that a
photon will reach Scooba clones eyes we
need to add all those arrows together we
do that by placing them all tail to head
just like we'd add regular vectors but
the arrows caught up in the spirals tend
to cancel themselves out leaving only a
few paths to contribute in any
noticeable way those are the ones near
the least time path termas principle
just comes from the probabilities of
photons
it's just probabilities but this is the
math trick right the photon is really
only taking in the least time path right
nope all the paths matter and I can
prove it let's keep things simple and
say there's a laser and a detector on
opposite sides of the screen quantum
tells us we must consider all paths
between the laser and detector it's just
that the probabilities of most paths
cancel themselves out leaving only the
least time path in the paths nearby but
what if we could slow some of those
photons down by just the right amount
the amount of time each path takes looks
something like this the center path is
the shortest time and they get
progressively longer the farther they
are from the center we know for earlier
that a material like glass will slow the
light down so we can adjust the timing
if we just put some glass in the way add
in glass along the shortest path means
the time it takes a photon to travel
that path is longer you can see the
graph has changed now what we want is
for more of the paths to contribute to
that probability we want the timing for
a bunch of these paths to be the same
that way they'll add together instead of
cancelling each other out each path
needs a different time adjustment
which calls for a different amount of
glass we get a device that looks like
this it's just a lens we just use
quantum mechanics to explain how lenses
work photons have many paths available a
lens just changes the travel time for
each of those paths that makes their
probabilities add together differently
and more paths contribute in a
noticeable way that's why this shape
focuses light kind of cool huh we've
seen that refraction or the bending of
light can cause all sorts of optical
illusions like this famous one with the
straw we could explain it with Snell's
law or even fair Maas principle of least
time but why those laws work comes down
to quantum mechanics light is made of
photons and photons are a quantum
mechanical object ultimately they're
they're probabilistic those
probabilities help us explain refraction
at multiple levels of complexity they
can even explain how lenses work it's
all really the same behavior it's all
about probabilities so got any questions
about refraction or just light in
general please ask in the comments
thanks for liking and sharing this video
don't forget to subscribe if you'd like
to keep up with us and until next time
remember it's okay to be a little crazy
the featured comment comes from Tom
koroa SHhhh kuru kuru shhhhh why look up
the refractive index when you can just
calculate it laziness okay terms got a
point though you can calculate it from
the electromagnetic field constants of
the material the equation looks like
this anyway thanks for watching